من بعد اشهر على بدايه الموسم الاول من
برنامج المسابقات الغنائي
تتويج الفائز في اللقب واللي كان من نصيب
المتسابقه هامس فكري
محبوب السعوديه
هو
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك لك يا همس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك لهمس
فازت واستحقت
وعبد العزيز وماجد ايضا نجوم وكلهم
يستحقون وصولهم لهذه المرحله كل المشتركين
اللي وصلوا معنا اصلا لسعود عادل هم فعلا
نجوم ساره
تاثر هامس كان واضح لحظه اعلان فوزا مثل
ما شفنا وكان واضح كمان في كلمه وجهتها
بعد الفوز لكل امراه سعوديه
احب اشكر بلادي السعوديه بلاد الحرمين
رؤيه 2030 اللي قدمت لنا مسمحت لنا الفرصه
ان احنا نوصل لهذا المكان شكرا ملك سلمان
شكرا ولي العهد تركي ما علينا شكرا مع
الشيخ
بلاد العز والخير والفخر اقول لهم شكرا
واوعدكم باذن الله اني اطور من نفسي واكون
عند حسن ظنكم باذن الله ان شاء الله انتم
اجمل ناس قابلتم في حياتي بليز قدموا على
سعودي ايدل كل مره سعوديه لازم تطمح وتحقق
حلمه من الان ان كان عندك موهبه الغناء
قدميها بلادنا السعوديه
احبك وان شاء الله انك تكونين فخوره فيني
احنا تعبنا وحققنا احلامنا بنتي حبيبتي
روحي انا اهديك نجاح وفوزي بكل ما فيني من
معاني
هذه النسخه هي الاولى من كانت برعايه هيئه
الترفيه ورئيسها المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
امس نشر تغريده بارك عبر للمتسابقه همس
فكري باللقب وقالوا انه سعيد بالشراكه بين
هيئه الترفيه ومجموعه ام بي سي همس فكري
كانت واحده من بين مجموعه من المتسابقين
اللي لفتوا الانظار في البرنامج ومن وقت
يعني ظهورها في تجارب الاداء لفتاه
الانبار انا راح اترككم مع مقطع مما غنت
خلال مشاركتها وعود القاكم الاسبوع المقبل
ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]
ومرت الايام
على شان
تبين الرج